hello I'm Jessica Clemens and welcome
back to New rockstars on Christmas Day
Netflix delivered an abundance of
treasures but no treasure compares to
the witcher's prequel blood origin now
if you're watching me and you're
watching this breakdown I assume that
you've watched The Big Bo but if not go
watch it it's literally four episodes
and very fun if you're like me and you
miss House of the dragon and rings of
power this gave you a little bump bump
if you know what I mean you also
technically could just start here this
is pre-witcher there's no real
requirement of seeing The Witcher before
this so regardless though I'm about to
spoil so just a warning I'm gonna spoil
completely the entire season blood
origin takes place long long before we
see our Witcher the Henry Cavill Witcher
it actually is the beginning before the
conjunction of the Spheres and we've all
heard of the conjunction of the Spheres
they can't get enough of it when Central
shattered the monolith as entria the
energy released with shatter space and
time itself so all planes of existence
multiple worlds cross through each other
then the elves weren't the only people
on the continent but humans monsters and
other creatures of the sort this was the
conjunction of the spears so over the
continent there's three large Elven
kingdoms basically at war with one
another's and Tria Shia and Darwin
zentria is actually Sentra for The
Witcher once the humans conquered it it
was changed to Sentra back in the day
though it was ruled by King darek who
after passing bequeatha to his son
alvater this is Merlin's brother who she
betrays killing not only the Royal
protectors the dog Clan but her brother
and the other clans and their monarchies
along with it prashia was ruled by King
midir who was betrothed to princess
Merwin in exchange for peace before his
untimely death they were protected by
the ravenclan Darwin was ruled by Queen
Nira and protected by the serpent Clan
Warriors all of these people were wiped
out in literally mere seconds on a coup
staged by merin's entry as Captain
Eridan and chief Sage Baylor who were
against the signing of the treaty all
along now the only way to do this was by
summoning a large beast from the barren
World by Chief Sage Baylor this monster
had the same energy as the Beast they
killed in episode 3. they essentially
came from the same Dimension along with
some other monsters later every person
has their own motive in this show and I
love it I love it so much Chief Sage
Baylor wants to become emperor and he's
paranoid no one will accept him because
he's lowborn they do kind of treat him
like crap though and they didn't even
let him chime in on the pill political
stuff so he has a right to be upset so
he decides he needs power only he can
wield that will make him a god amongst
elves he needs the disembodied voices
chaos magic to which she confirms you
must sacrifice everything for it no
matter the cost and as we know it always
comes with a cost Jennifer lost her
powers after using chaos magic in season
1 at the Battle of Sonnen chaos is
clearly more violent temperamental and
unpredictable Fire magic is dangerous
because it consumes your soul and body
this differs from the magic the elves
used to practice which was like Druid
like Magic Drawing from nature only
blood origin confirms that chaos magic
originated from another world brought
into ours it also confirms that Baylor
with that chaos magic created the wild
Hunt brought monsters into the realm and
without his chaos magic we wouldn't have
the conjunction of the Spheres and like
taken to the families of those
slaughtered in this Coupe have come for
Revenge I will find you and I will kill
you now some of these Heroes belong to
Clans and you can usually join clans by
birth sometimes children of these Clans
are sent away to swords Masters and
Druids to provide training and if they
dip out it's reflected on them and their
mentors which we kind of see in the Lark
AKA Ella played by Sophia Brown she's
currently a roving Bard singing Tales
all over the town's unknowingly putting
faith into every low-born ear over the
continent she's basically the leader of
the seven in my opinion she starts the
whole like Revenge story and receiving
the vision from ethelyn but her story is
very complicated and very Justified she
was born into the Raven Clan and trained
to be a warrior and protector of the
Persia royal family she also was trained
by skien the last member of the ghost
tribe who joins the team later Ella was
plagued with horrible guilt for
committing horrible things to innocent
lives in the name of their leader and
Kingdom from a young age so it just
wasn't for her you know how it goes so
she left the clan to fulfill a career as
a Bard that is until her sister and her
are ambushed leaving her sister killed
she realizes the guards are trying to
kill her belong to all three kingdoms
who hated each other so something must
be at play if these attackers are all
trying to keep them from getting to the
treaty signing this is when her revenge
tail like really starts additionally I
mentioned receiving a vision from
ethelin earlier if that sounds familiar
it should Francesca said that she was
Guided by ethylen and Visions where she
was lost in a maze of dead bodies in
season two then we see the deathless
mother use her form to trick her later
but we see her now in the flesh as a
regular bar mate she's known in Witcher
season 2 as a high profit also known as
the white robed one and many elf's trust
and follow whatever she says though at
first they believe her vision to be like
a sickness they start coming true even
when slightly interpreted wrong she's
kinda like the Bible we see another one
of her prophecies from the book in
season one episode seven through series
blood origin has everything I love about
Dark Fantasy fights monsters lore the
only thing blood origin doesn't give me
is a chance to be part of the action
which is why I want to play gourd Gord
is a single player Adventure strategy
game based on the Slavic folklore it's a
grim Mysterious World where your job is
to help the tribe of the Dawn survive
and thrive Gordon is a city Builder with
survival elements like yes you get to
put up walls and grow your gourd from a
humble settlement into a formidable
Fortress and there are procedurally
generated quests to keep you busy four
hours hunting legendary creatures and
uncovering ancient secrets and more but
the thing that's really exciting for me
is the sanity system every aspect of
your settlers lives from illness and
hunger to the death of their kin can
impact their sanity levels which works
in real life too once they've gone
through too much you run the risk of
them fleeing your rule or Worse breaking
down and tearing Your settlement apart
from within them oh God Gordon is
available to wishlist now on Steam and
will be available to play soon click the
link in the description box to learn a
little bit more about it then we meet
y'all stoneheart played by Lauren
sofurian and I know I'm pronouncing that
last name wrong and I'm sorry formerly
of the dog Clan and the big reveal in
blood origin is that he was the first
Witcher briefly if y'all stoneheart was
banished from zentria for Sleeping With
Merlin at the beginning of the season
and through a lot of complicated Hoops
he decides to join and help Ella on her
quest to avenge those fallen in the coup
seen as his father was slayed by the
monster and his sister's neck slipped by
Merwin herself now being the first
wizard prototype is completely sketchy
as we see Central and zakari plan the
trial of the grasses they made a potion
and fuse his heart to a monster from a
different dimension and though he died
briefly he did come back to as this kind
of Witcher sort of Witcher though the
mission went as planned unfortunately if
y'all loses his mind and starts killing
his allies and must be Mercy killed by
Ella his love now from season two when
vesamere is introducing past witchers to
Siri there's no mention of y'all so the
trial has probably gone forgotten if
y'all being the first Witcher prototype
is actually still again very big
essentially they don't uncover the trial
of the grasses for a long time after
that and even in losing syndrome zakari
is still alive which means she could a
pass on the knowledge of what she knew
making the original prototype and fjal
or B eventually Master the process and
passed it on because we know in
Nightmare of the wolf redrick knew the
mutagenic Alchemy to make witchers but
died at the Battle of CareMore so the
knowledge died with him but in season 2
vestamir and tris can create the
mutagenic formula for witchers from an
old wise Tale the Elder blood can create
witchers per perhaps now that we know
that avalock has quite possibly
perfected time travel we can get
concrete answers on how to make the
Elixir completely right and foolproof
who better to test it on than my willing
and eager lab assistant speaker then we
meet skien the last member of the ghost
tribe played by Michelle yo now she's
the last member because the first king
of centria King Derek poisoned their
tribe's water supply and took Soul
Reaver as a trophy when they refused to
fight for zentria the ghost tribe were
honorable and couldn't be bought so they
didn't really back any Kingdom they
believe their sacred blade provided a
gateway to the afterlife which could be
the ritual we see ski and performing at
the very end we then meet Callan AKA
brother death played by Hugh Novelli and
again I know I'm pronouncing that name
wrong who we learn has a grudge against
the Empire's soldiers who wiped out the
village who took him in it's also never
mentioned but Netflix's website has him
listed with a serpent Clan now his lover
is akari who saw good in him when he
wandered through her Mist though his
past holds a lot of killing she took a
chance on him and they fell in love
which is really sweet he introduces us
to the Mages and Celestial beings
Zakarian Central played by Lizzie Janice
and Zach Wyatt now they weren't actual
siblings but having shared the same
magical traits and being very close to
kari's mother took him in we first see
Central imprisoned by the chief Sage
Baylor as intria now we know that these
monoliths were created by Dwarven
ancients burying them to bring fertile
bounty to the land as meldoff recounts
But Central figured out they could be
used to open portals to other worlds he
and Baylor worked together to uncover
their secrets while syndril used this as
an opportunity to seek resources for the
elves Baylor had a different negative
idea oh hell Central felt the presence
of something dark and Gray in the barren
World urging him to stop diving into its
Secrets but Baylor disagreed stole his
book of monoliths and locked him away in
Gentry zakari I spoke about earlier
being the last surviving mage of the
seven left behind who co-created the
first Witcher prototype last but not
least we meet our last member to join
the seven my favorite meldoff played by
Francesca Mills Melrose begins her
journey avenging her lover Gwen who was
murdered by zentrian soldiers her spirit
now lives within the hammer and meldoff
and her Sikh revenge on those who killed
her her motive is pretty clear on
joining now other than the seven there's
a ton of other very important pieces of
information brought to the storyline
like Captain Eridan played by Jacob
Collins Levy so there's a ton of
backstory to air it in like the
challenges with his partner staging the
coup switching sides but once Baylor
sucks him into a new portal forcing him
to a Barren land alone walking half dead
he finds a bone-shaped helmet in the Red
Sand which is the helmet of the leader
of the wild Hunt the wild Hunt is
brought up in the second book The Sword
of Destiny and is the focus of the third
game the wild Hunt they're mentioned in
the first episode episode as an omen of
War as The Witcher showrunner depicts
them there are skeletal writers on
skeletal horses and even in the second
season Neville and refers to them as a
Porton of Doom claiming he saw them
himself they're basically an old folk
tale to some especially girl this is
until in season 2 episode 8 we get a
glimpse of them they tell Siri to come
join the wild Hunt her place is with
them so we can expect to see them in
season three making their triumphant
return but as for blood Origins we know
a piece of their origin story the other
members of the wild Hunt could be some
of the men sucked into the black hole we
just don't know yet showrunner Lauren
Schmidt mentioned that the production
designer began drawings with the wild
Hunt and that all seven would be
different riders with different
backstories and will dive into them as
the story goes like we did with Eridan
the monoliths are also really important
and their connection to chaos magic
since we didn't know much about the
models before when gural and estrad are
venturing to the side of the monolith in
season two isstrid says stories of Voice
Sarah as a monolith scars from the
conjunction leftover points of impact
which we know is not true per meldoff's
conversation with brother death the
monoliths are made of stellocyte which
is basically indestructible yet we now
know that syndral and Siri can topple
them the monoliths were used by Baylor
to take you to a Barren world with a
Celestial female voice and we don't
really know who that is but I think this
could be the deathless mother from
season two possibly breaking the model
that allowed her to escape but she
eventually found herself bound to a Hut
or B she could be the embodiment of
chaos magic itself which could still tie
her to the deathless mother in yennefer
we also meet avalock Empress Marin's
protector played by Samuel blanken which
is another big moment for him and the
plot of the show is the introduction of
time travel after finding Central's book
you realize Central figured out the
equation to time travel then appeared in
the doorway later where we saw baby Siri
dress as a lowborn playing with the
children from the first season so we can
assume he figured out the equation and
can jump through space and time itself
in Witcher lore avalock plays a huge
part in series story and in the books
he's concerned and obsessed with her to
a controversial Point as some would say
avalock was supposed to marry Laura
Doran series ancestor who we see in
season two though she falls in love with
the human Greg lot I probably pronounced
that wrong and I'm sorry and Lady of the
Lake he imprisoned Syrian demand she
bear a child with their Monarch
sometimes he helps her as a mentor with
her magical powers and in Witcher 3 he
saves her from the wild Hunt but he also
tried to like replicate the Laura Jean
AKA Elder blood and claims he's
protecting Siri along with it it's just
like a mystery he's bad in the books and
okay in the games he bounces from like a
sketchy evil friend to a sketchy evil
enemy all the time portrait of Siri I
think
really captured you sure havelock's only
interested in you for your magic
abilities
very funny
uh we don't it's it's weird in an
interview with collider the showrunners
Declan dabara and Lauren Schmidt said
time travel is going to be part of the
main series because avalock is part of
the main series and of course that's one
of series Mains Powers is traveling
through time and space so instead of
seeing avalock as the horrible figure
maybe he can appear in season three
watching and tracking Siri and her
powers as they grow with her Elder blood
but you know nine times out of ten
everyone's intention with elder blood is
bad and selfish so who really knows he
could show up as a mentor or he could be
there to divide Siri and girl it's kind
of like grogu with the Mandalorian and
the Jedis maybe he's like there to
pressure her to make a choice between
The Witcher or following his path it's
all still kind of murky if he's going to
be good or bad but he's there
nonetheless the season concludes with
the Lark now pregnant with y'all's child
and she receives another Prophecy from
ithelin the time of the spears is upon
us and shed lost across the skies cast
adrift in time ever searching for love
lost and left behind a lark Siege shall
cower carry forth the first note of the
song that ends all times and one of her
blood shall sing the last yeah yeah you
get it the first sentence refers to the
conjunction of the Spheres and shed
refers to the race of elves during blood
origin that inhabit the continent by the
time of The Witcher they'll be
blackballed because we know that they're
treated like crap now the biggest
takeaway from the final line is about
the Lark seed when Zella had sex with
fjaw after his transformation into the
Prototype Witcher it sure enough the
child would be different due to his
transformation you know the one of her
blood shall sing the last something this
likely ties to Siri and her Elder blood
that offspring of that first Witcher in
Ella carry something much more it has to
it could be similar to what Laura said
in the second season the world will die
a Miss Frost and be reborn of the new
Sun reborn of Elder blood of the seed
that has been sown so if Siri isn't
causing the World's End she's deeply
involved in it I think it's more likely
that she's the long descendant of the
two and this is Elder blood came from
the Prototype butcher elf himself but
sometimes Ethan's prophecies are up to
interpretation so the song could
literally be about The Bard yaskir or
possibly the love always searching as
Jennifer but I truly think it's about
Siri and in the world and being a long
descendant of y'all and Ella there's
also small parts of the story that sort
of go unnoticed and don't seem as
important but are worth noting like the
Bo's introduction we open to a strange
war with yaskir almost being killed he's
saved and the story is narrated going
forward by sinache played by Minnie
Driver as yasukir says she's a
time-stopping shape-shifting probably
gonna eat me without salt at some point
Storyteller which is half true we don't
know her true form Declan dabara says
she's a creature that moves through time
collecting stories and bringing them
back to life she's the one telling
yaskir the tale of what happened 1200
years ago so he can remind everyone of
how it began we know from blood origin
the Lark song helped the lowborn rise up
maybe we'll need that song for the
people and the tale spread so everyone
can be warned and inspired and is also
cute the ravenclan Lark now passes on
the tail to the Sandpiper it's just a
bunch of bird puns solarith is mentioned
by Merwin throughout the story
especially how solareth followed comets
in the sky now known as solar its eye to
the continent and stole the land from
the dwarves ushering in The Golden Age
Of The Elves contrary to what we see in
the witch sure where elves are
downtrodden and suffered under human
torture we see in blood origin the coup
was the first step in the Elvish decline
it seems as though with or without
humans coming Merwin neglected her
people who rose up against her leading
her to her death solereth worked as an
inspiration to Merlin and blood origin
now solareth did push the Elven race
ahead but on the corpses of the dwarves
and when she died the continent became
Three Kingdoms at war with each other
Marin just wanted to bring back that
peace and Conquer other worlds along
with it in the name of the elves and now
look the elves are down bad my dude
they're horribly off briefly the Battle
of Brooklyn is also mentioned when Ella
and Phil fight y'all took Ella's
cousin's eye during that war and we've
seen the Brookhill in forest in season
one when Syria was lost that is it for
my breakdown of blood origin I genuinely
liked it it's super fast it's four
episodes one hour each I think it was
nicely paced I also have a thirst for
all things fantasy any time of the year
so it was quenched for me though this
takes place thousands of years before
The Witcher series these Tales are great
to take note of and now for season three
we can monitor where people are coming
from and what's possible let me know
what you thought of Witcher blood origin
and if you'll be watching season three
when it drops follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars remember breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]